[Music]
all right
james kelly simone biles real quick
what have you all been hearing it's been
very um
divisive i mean you know you're hearing
that she's um
doing great for taking care of herself
and thinking of her team but then
there's been this side that's been
she's selfish and she's letting her
teammates down and she's just thinking
about herself
it just seems it's just everybody has an
opinion on it and it's
pretty strong opinions too for something
that doesn't affect them
so here's just my randy i'd love to hear
y'all pop in
you've got the greatest gymnast of all
time
and if you go back and look at some of
her stuff like she's won gold medals
with
broken bones in her feet she's all kinds
of injuries where she keeps going
to do the things that she does behind
closed doors is hours and hours hundreds
of hours hundreds of
falls from heights onto mats and
eating it and bashing your head and your
arms and your elbows on poles and
beams and whatever so number one we're
gonna take off the table
this she's weak that's off the table
that's absurd at a level that's so
stupid
so if anybody listening has said she's
just weak
you're wrong you're an absolute [ __ ]
you're wrong okay so that's off table
number two to do a flip
off a high dive into a pool
scares me it's not easy right
to do 88 flips in the air whatever crap
she's doing and spinning and doing
circles and twisters and whatever
in the air and then by the way if if her
foot hits the ground and it moves one
inch
we're all like oh she tanked at me
by the way as it i think i saw the other
day she's the sole surviving
person who's still on the team who's
involved in all of that
those years of sexual assault from that
evil nasser idiot
so you're you're carrying the face of
sexual assault survivors
to the globe you're the number one on
planet earth and you've gone through
all of these these practices where your
mental toughness is
every second of every practice
and then by the way she's known in the
city of houston for showing up in the
middle of the night during hurricanes
and food drives
not as a celebrity but hey i've got time
i can throw boxes
so she's known as the person who helps
her community out
you've got these other countries talking
about race stuff i mean
to say she's quote unquote mentally weak
is idiot
insane off the table you can't have that
there either
right so now i'm left with the
one of the greatest athletes of in my
lifetime
the greatest gymnast of all time who
says
hey last night i was flipping and flying
around the air
and i can't do it like i know myself i
know my body i know my brain
i've got to step back
i don't know how anybody eating cheetos
sitting on their couch
i don't know how anybody like with
domino's pizza delivery knocking on the
front door
can sit there and go oh my gosh she
hates america she's a
coward what a wimp she signed up for
dude i it's
maddening it's maddening
when somebody of her caliber character
somebody for character of mental
fortitude somebody for a
caliber of of professional athlete
somebody of her character who suffered
the trauma she suffered somebody who's
carrying
earth the face of the us olympics
stands up and says i can't i i gotta
step out
and by the way turns it over to somebody
who didn't make the team
and then what that this german wins a
gold medal
what a great turn of events by the way
our team is so good i can step
out and the person who replaced her who
hadn't made the team wins gold
right so here's the thing number one
i i i don't know i'll never know
simone biles like we're not gonna go
hang out i don't know her i don't know
her mental health i can't speak to that
what i can speak to is just the facts
that to call her
a wimp to call her weak to call her
mentally whatever
is absolute insanity
absolute insanity if you played high
school sports
that doesn't that you don't get to speak
into olympic athlete
if you were like a cool tight end on
your football team
you don't know what it's like to carry
sexual assault race the face of u.s
olympics
internationally during a pandemic you
don't get to speak on that stuff
and so when somebody of that caliber or
any caliber says
hey here's what i'm going through right
now what if we all just said
oh okay and you trusted the person
talking to you what if we just did that
it takes all of our angst out of our
souls it doesn't it it
keeps us from poisoning ourselves hoping
simone biles is going to feel it
absolute madness
madness in it you know what we talk
about simone biles
james and kelly but it's also somebody
calls in sick at work
and we're at our house or we're at the
office and we're tired and we're
frustrated and we instantly go they're
not sick
or if they had just done this and they
or they eat like that of course
what if we just went oh man i hope he
gets feeling better
or when we're driving down the road and
a guy cuts us off and we're like that
guy
he just what if we just said man i hope
he's doing okay
if you had a comment a negative comment
about some anything other than
i hope she's okay
man check yourself man
look in the mirror you don't have no
idea
and we've got a culture that just thinks
we can comment on everything
especially negatively
just stop i don't know that's my thought
that's my thoughts
i know the least about it than probably
anybody in this room but the thing
first of all like you never know there's
always more behind the scenes
going on than you know yeah we'll never
know about and
unless you're in that position you don't
know what you would do you may
have caved under the pressure a long
time ago you know like nobody knows
unless they're in that position but yeah
the everybody needing to comment on
everything happening all the time is
just so stupid and exhausting i just
don't understand it like what
and then to see that person say i can't
do this but i'm gonna go out and suck it
up
and in the humiliation embarrassment and
i'm gonna cheer my team on
come on man you know i i just looking at
something
of a caliber of character that we just
don't see very often and to turn that
into
what a wimp or what a week or she's
gonna regret this whatever
probably not and if you look at the
number of previous athletes
that have come out and said man i wish i
would have had the courage to do what
she was doing
because i was starting to you know
michael phelps has been big out there
saying
man i almost had a breakdown i almost
lost it yeah
and they're applauding her for the
courage that she had and wishing they
had done that right
and you know we don't have a clue what
the kind of pressure they're under
i i can't even wrap my head around it
right i can't wrap my head around it
but i can know this one of the ways
people ask me all the time dude what you
always just look like you're just chill
like you just walk through life pretty
light it's because i just choose to
believe people
and when they tell me they're struggling
i choose to go man i'm sorry
and i'm also a guy that says tell tells
myself a lot dillon you gotta suck it up
i know you don't feel good i know you
don't
feel great or whatever you gotta get
your workout done like i'm all about
that i love jocko too you gotta suck it
up and you gotta do it
and then there comes a moment when
somebody is doing somersaults in the air
and they say if i do this wrong i'm
going to land on my neck i'm going to
break my neck
i'm not in the right head space i got to
step out and then you go
sweet who's next and then in this case
who's next won a gold medal
so rad dude so rad
so that's my thought on simone biles
it's my it's just my thought on life man
everybody stop commenting on everything
trying to find something negative
let's celebrate people let's support
people
and yeah dude if it's you look in your
mirror suck it up work hard work hard
suck it up and work real hard
and if you can't you can't and then have
the courage to say
i need to step back for a minute and you
step back for a minute and if she does
regret this 40 years from now it's her
regret to have not yours
because america got their gold medal
that you needed so bad